foreign
hey what's going on it's kind of dark
again I turned the lights on yeah you
look look where it is where is it oh
yeah well I didn't do it I haven't been
in here what do you want me to do there
you go okay there you go this one's too
low you need some soft pink light yeah
to make you look all
soft and beautiful
nope in the background
so what's going on what's going on
everybody it's Monday night
and time once again for a movie review
now that how we stumbled across this
movie was kind of
interesting because Saturday night
we didn't go out so we were kind of I
was like well we'll think of something
to watch for whatever and we was like
we're gonna watch Poltergeist because
remember we were talking about that the
other day and then I was like well we've
already reviewed that but I was like
well [__] it we might watch it anyway
but then I noticed that Amazon Prime hi
Pokey had cocaine bear
so I was like oh maybe we should watch
that because a lot of people have have
mentioned mentioned it
so we watched that first and that was
actually pretty entertaining and then we
watched Poltergeist and then we were
kind of a little bit inebriated and we
kind of wanted to watch another movie
because it was like a triple feature
kind of kind of deal and we were
scrolling through Amazon Prime and we
noticed this little movie right here I
had actually never heard of this movie
but we were like well it's from 1974.
it's like a sci-fi horror movie and
Donald Pleasence is in it it's it's so
so was Tom uh although Tom Baker that
Tom Baker like Doctor Who Tom Baker so
which we didn't even realize that until
we started watching it and we saw in the
credits because like his name came up I
was like wait the Tom Baker yeah holy
[__] this is star-studded yeah so we
have to watch this yeah we didn't know
it was a British movie not at first not
until not until I saw Tom Baker and the
movie starts off with a bunch of like uh
stock footage now it's I actually found
out that it wasn't stock footage they
actually I know but they actually did
make because we made a lot of jokes
about like Edward being like I got
making a whole entire movie it's just
out of the stock footage it was showing
like uh stop motion uh [__] plants
or like what do they call that um time
lapse photography of plants and
mushrooms growing
you're like what the hell this movie's
gonna be [__] cheesy as [__]
but we were just kind of goofing on it
but as the movie kept going we liked it
we're like this is a pretty good thing
pretty good they had good special
effects good story
uh it was homage and a bunch of other
stuff and homage freaks a lot oh big
time yeah that movie actually there was
one scene in there that was a pretty
much a direct yeah I don't want to say
ripoff that seems a little uncharitable
but yeah it was it was a direct homage
of the whole um we accept you one of us
yeah they don't know what you're talking
about probably yeah they do everybody
come on everybody says everybody knows
about freaks it had a uh movies got a
bunch of good looking British chicks in
them you get to see them all naked
then most of them the British knew what
the audience just wanted there's like
all hot chicks in the audience see their
boobies at some point
yeah well
and then uh
gruesome murders and monsters
and uh Donald Pleasence [__] tearing
up the [__] scenery just uh this was
I I feel like this was a slightly more
subdued role for him
um but he did kind of go chewing the
scenery toward the end yeah was he
supposed to be having a German accent at
the beginning
right I kind of think that's right and I
think that was pretty common like in
British sci-fi horror of the era like
all of the mad scientist characters
always had to have German accents for
that very reason and uh Tom Baker said
it he plays a guy from a sideshow uh
Carnival he's uh like some kind of
hideously deformed guy and he's working
for the mad scientist he's basically
he's basically uh [__] what's the
guy's name [__]
from from Frankenstein this is a
Frankenstein story which is what was
that now what's that kind of what was
what was the uh what was uh Dr
Frankenstein's sidekick
new Igor Igor yeah it's kind of like
Igor
um but he's still he's still Tom Baker
and he's wearing his [__] Doctor Who
outfit pretty much the only thing he's
lacking is the scarf you got the Hat
yeah it's like the same floppy hat the
[__] the uh the
the big [__] velvet [__] trench
coat Overcoat
and uh the side of his face is all
[__] up
and actually the uh
the special effects are pretty good for
the time I mean this is I mean it's it's
very clearly like a a zero budget movie
like not a zero budget but
um but you know a low budget movie so
like a doctor about like a doctor right
so some of the monsters look kind of
cobbled together but yeah they still
look kind of cool and like kind of
creative I thought yeah I would say
they're a little bit better than a
Doctor Who episode from the time just a
little bit but because there was there
was some shitty Doctor Who episodes
and then there were some real good ones
um but uh from this era but I'd put it
on part like Doctor Who
yeah the thing about it is that and I'm
not super clear on this movie came out
in 1974.
and I think that Tom Baker had either
was either just about to get the just
about to start as Doctor Who or had just
started as Doctor Who like when this
movie came out I think he started in 75
so yeah so it might have been like
slightly before maybe he just got the
part so he hadn't so I don't know if
he'd actually like been Doctor Who yet
like where people would go to this movie
and be like oh we're gonna go see doctor
who accept he's available probably not
probably not I think it was slightly
after
and this was interesting facts this was
directed by a dude named Jack Cardiff if
you know anything about the British film
industry uh that name will be very
familiar because he is actually one of
considered one of Britain's Finest
cinematographers and uh one one was
nominated for multiple Oscars actually
he worked on um The Red Shoes death on
the Nile African queen he was the
cinematographer on that and then like in
the 80s he did Ghost Story the Peter
Stroud movie he did Conan the Destroyer
yeah he did cat's eye he did Rambo too
so yeah but this was he had directed
like a handful of movies like I said
he's mostly known as a cinematographer
but I think this was the last movie that
he directed and I don't really think
this movie is also called the freak
maker
like I don't know what title it's better
known as nowadays like on Amazon it's
called the mutations but I heard for a
time it was actually better known as the
freak maker
which kind of makes more sense but it's
more allured title I suppose that's what
he was making
he's making uh animal plant hybrids play
Animals play animals
[Laughter]
yeah well okay now did he did he specify
Donald pleasence's character why he was
doing he was like a genetic scientist
right yeah and so he's got this thing
where he's gonna
um
you know kind of fuse together plants
and animals for some supposedly good
purpose
not really sure what that purpose was
a race of people yes
we were laughing about that [__]
a race of atomic Superman yeah that
would you know what I mean Friday
monster people erase
well I always say it like that because
when they did Bride of the monster on
Mystery Science Theater like when Bella
goes he said that it did kind of sound
like racist people when he said it like
in his accent so it's like so that was
like a recurring joke that they would go
it was like is he creating a rice and
pimple yeah yeah but uh that's what we
were saying about it it's a really good
Atomic Superman and stuff like that but
yeah so
so he wants to
fuse plants and animals together just
because because it would be a neat idea
I suppose or to take over to Borrowed or
whatever I don't really know
um but so he's doing that he's feeding
bunny rabbits to his big Audrey 2 plant
and um so there's that and then he has
like Tom Baker plays this guy Mr Lynch
right his name is Mr Lynch the
character's name
and he runs a circus sideshow
and he's helping Donald Pleasence out
because Donald Pleasence has promised
him you know obviously not sincerely as
it turns out
um but he's like yeah I'll fix your
[__] up face if you procure me some
like guinea pigs and buy guinea pigs I
mean like human beings that I can
experiment on and like inject them with
plant juice and make them turn into like
walking yeah um Venus fly traps and
whatnot yeah and of course you got to
start with like one of the hottest girls
in the movie
well yeah yeah you gotta start with her
he it turns her into a damn salamander
yeah yeah you just see the head though
yeah well like I said they didn't have
like the budget to show like a lot of
stuff although like I said the some of
the monsters were actually like pretty
good there you can tell that they're
just kind of cobbled together out of you
know
to foam and spray paint but it's like
you know I've seen a lot worse so I
actually really did we had a really good
time with this movie I didn't expect it
I didn't expect it to like be um well I
think the thing about it is that as
cheesy as the premises are sometimes
like the British always kind of seemed
to take it take them very seriously
and I think that that works to the
movie's favor yeah you know what I'm
saying he well he eventually got the
process right and he uh
took one dude and synthesized him with
some plants and some plantimals and
turned him into basically a big humanoid
Venus flytrap yeah his chest would open
up and he'd [__] digest people which
was pretty cool actually it's pretty
good he could still talk
and uh who was funny is that
everybody was everybody was chasing him
away you know with uh and screaming when
they would when they saw him
but he was still him he was still you
know yeah he's like don't turn the
lights on because right I don't look
quite the same as I used right and then
just on a side note he ate a bum like
that was no big deal
as one does yeah and then just continued
on like he didn't do anything
he was still a good guy Kinda Yeah he
was a good guy
yeah he saved some people well I mean I
guess they were just saying that well he
couldn't help it really I mean it wasn't
his fault he didn't turn himself into a
Venus flytrap person yeah no like that
was all that was all Donald Pleasence he
came out came out of damn Timbs
I was like [__] yeah that's probably you
know when you're a hobo like that that's
probably the last thing the last way you
think you're gonna go is eaten by a
Venus flytrap man I mean can you imagine
and like and it would take a long time
to die too because Venus flytrap like it
kind of just like puts all his digestive
juices in there yeah and then you're
just kind of like stuck in there like
digesting yeah and you're still alive oh
that's a baker as the deformed guy goes
to a hooker that was another good that
was a good scene
sees an ad he was looking at all the
strip clubs and Jen said man the strip
clubs look just like that in England
it's just like a damn storefront I don't
know about now but last time some women
in it yeah but last time I was there
paintings of women it looked like that
it's a weird way of doing it and uh he
sees a a want ad somebody had attacked
just a little three by five card on
there said that offering dancing lessons
and what was it rapid dancing or
something and I guess it was dancing
lessons
so he goes to the address and uh yeah
sure enough
it was a hooker
she drops her clothes let's all see what
else yeah it was euphemisms yes I would
like some dancing lessons right wink
wink of course his head his face is
totally [__] up and he tried to hide
it she goes oh I've seen everything it
doesn't matter she takes it off I like
that she was just like totally not
phased she's like whatever I've seen it
all but
well the kind of sad thing and it's he's
unquestionably a villain
but they do give him like a little bit
of
they they did try to make them slightly
more sympathetic because they made a big
show of him like paying the prostitute
extra to tell her to tell him that she
loved him yeah yeah because he would
never well they're trying to say that he
was doing this you know to get approval
right and to be normal
so which is understandable yeah but you
know he was killing people to get it
done yeah which that's just not the way
to go about things you're not going to
lose any friends it was a mad dream
anyway that scientists couldn't fix him
well he had no intention of fixing him
he was just trying to I mean that was
just his muscle yeah and he just like
kept stringing him along and saying he
was gonna fix his face like because he
was just getting him to do [__] for him
that's all and in this one Tom Baker can
fight unexplained unexplicably he'd
never really uh seemed to be a real
physical guy to me but he was [__]
kicking people's asses and this
he looked big and I mean well Tom Baker
was a pretty tall dude yeah he's tall
yeah but I don't know if he was just
like a little bit bulky not fat but he
looked like bulkier so I don't know if
that was just like the outfit they had
him in or he just seemed bigger because
of the makeup or yeah wearing that coat
yeah maybe that's what it was but he did
seem like this big lumbering yeah so so
what we didn't get into was there so all
of this [__] is going on over here with
Donald Pleasence like turning people
into plants and so forth and then on the
other side Mr Lynch who is Tom Baker's
character he runs a circus Sideshow and
whenever Donald Pleasence when one of
his experiments goes awry
um he actually kind of is like hey
here's a new exhibit
for your circus Sideshow you know
because he [__] up the one hot chick
like the first one that he takes and
he's like whoopsie well put that one on
the [__] mistake pile and then he and
then they kind of put her in the circus
as um with the lizard woman or something
like that and they only show her a
little bit but much like I mean this is
very very very very very obviously
homaging freaks from 1932 the Todd
Browning movie
um in and also in the sense that they
actually do use real Sideshow performers
um in this and I know that some people
had a problem with that
um just as they did in the 1930s because
they thought it was exploitative or
whatever but
okay while I would argue that this movie
because it was the 70s was probably
slightly more exploitative than the 1932
one but still like the sideshare
performers in this are still all
sympathetic characters and they're kind
of the ones getting [__] over they're
not the villains you know what I mean
and they're actually portrayed quite uh
sympathetically so I didn't really have
any problem with it and actually I
recognized
um and you've if there's like famous
there's famous pictures of this dude
um his name was he was called Popeye and
he was the dude that he could like pop
his eyeballs out their sockets like
really far yeah there's like gifts to
him and it's like he was quite a famous
like Sideshow performer he didn't have
to do anything either he could just open
his eyes yeah it is it is Almighty
freaky looking weird I'm gonna say yeah
but he said that uh Tom Baker never
really was dead yeah I guess I guess
you're probably right it was hard it's
hard to tell what Tom Baker's build was
most he always had that coat on he
always had that coat on and he was uh
wearing a lot of clothes he just I
remember him being tall
probably medium build might have been
big around the waist for all I know
it's hard to say yeah I was like I it's
not like I was
um like really looking at him all that
closely
you know and especially in this movie
because he just had the code on most of
the time and he was like skulking around
with that like Elephant Man looking face
but but yeah so so Popeye was in this
and then they had um they had a bearded
lady
they had a couple of um little people
and they didn't have the I mean they
didn't have like
in Todd Browning's freaks obviously they
had you know what they used to call
pinheads
they had those and they had like um
the human torso and sorry so they didn't
have anything that
out there like in this one it was mostly
just like you know a bearded lady and a
couple of little people and the dude
that could pop his eyeballs out yeah and
who else
oh the alligator girl she's kind of
famous too like and said well I mean if
you know anything about Sideshow history
she's kind of famous but um but she had
like that that skin condition that made
her look all scaly and stuff yeah she
was in a tail although I think she was
only in one scene or something
but it's weird because the really the
only main main character like one of the
little people who's a guy who played
who's like
he's sort of like partnering with Lynch
like because he sort of like helps him
run the sideshow but then like he kind
of turns on him in the end when he finds
out like what's been going on like where
he's getting all of these new performers
from quote unquote these new exhibits
and when he finds out he's like yeah
[__] that noise but it's interesting
because I feel like a lot of these I saw
a review that pointed out they're like
well the thing about Todd Browning's
freaks was that a lot of the actors that
were obviously real Sideshow performers
but a lot of them were also um
immigrants a lot of them were foreign so
they had like really thick accents and
stuff whereas like in this one they
seemed like they were mostly British or
American and actually they were
they were actually quite good actors I
thought which which you would think
because you know they're performers
they're Sideshow performers you would
think that they would have to have some
acting experience I know that like
acting like live and doing [__] in a
movie is not the same yeah quite the
same their roles were simple though
right that's true but like I said they
definitely there's one scene in there
where they're having like it was like a
birthday party or something for one of
the for one of their performers and
Lynch comes in and gets all pissy pants
about something or other
and start stomping all over the cake
even though they're being nice to him
and like and they and he definitely
homages freaks because he's like because
I think they even say like word for word
like we accept you one of I don't know
if they go they don't go one of us
whatever they don't do that but I mean
almost and they almost wanted to do that
but then he gets all like like I'm not
one of you you guys are Freaks and I'm
just a normal guy with a [__] up
looking face you know what I mean like
he's he had some issues about not
wanting to be one of them so there was
that too so there was like some other
kind of stuff going on in there like
it's um it's cheesy for sure but
I was I don't know I think we were
expecting it because like I said by this
time of the night it was like kind of
later we'd already watched a couple of
movies we were kind of drunk and I was
like oh that looks kind of fun and Tom's
like yeah put that on and so we were
kind of like I said we were kind of
goofing on it at the beginning but then
I was just kind of well that was like a
lot better
it was a solid flick it was yes I had a
good time with it actually like I said
it's pretty cheesy but had you seen it
back in the early 80s or late 70s it
would have been a solid flick
something you'd see on [__] Cinemax
or HBO in the middle of night
yeah it's weird because I don't think I
had ever heard of it yeah never heard of
it and I like a lot of British films
from that era
um so I'm surprised that I had actually
never never heard of it and especially
with Donald Pleasence in it and yeah and
Tom Baker in it you'd think that I would
have heard of it before now there were
there were a lot of worse movies to come
after this I mean you know
it wasn't you know
a monument to suckage it was good for
what it was you know well one of the
best things I think about me being
um a huge MST fan
is that you are willing to give movies
an incredible amount of leeway because a
lot of the movies that they show on
mst3k are just terrible awful yeah and
it's like so you know how but I mean
they did some decent ones too I'm not
gonna lie like I've seen some ones on
there that I would totally watch like
not even on MST because they were like
really entertaining but they've done
some movies on there that were just the
worst and it's like so whenever anybody
like says to me like oh that movie was
so bad or something like that I'm like
let me make you a list you want to see
some really really really bad movies
it's like that's nothing so I you know
I'm kind of a lot more willing to give
movies the benefit of the doubt because
I've seen some of the worst movies ever
and they can get a million times worse
than what you're imagining
and this one
um actually like I said this was
actually really entertaining I had a
really good time with this and it's
interesting that it's not better known I
guess maybe it has like a slight cult
following but I don't know I had never
heard of it and like I said I like a lot
of movies from this era like I like a
lot of British movies from this era
especially like all like kind of the
Amicus like Anthology movies
um and stuff like that and there was one
that this I don't know if this reminded
me of it but there's a movie came that
came out I think it was 72 maybe and it
was called
um the aspects
and it was kind of like a Sci-Fi
frankensteinish kind of thing not so
much people that were mutants but people
that um but a guy that was trying to
capture
um the thing that came and got your soul
like when you died
and he wanted to like capture that and
so you could live forever
um and that was actually that was kind
of one more obscure one that I had heard
of and then like I went to watch and I
was like that was also like pretty
entertaining I wrote a big long thing
about it
but um so yeah so I do like a lot of
movies from this era but I'm just
surprised I'd never heard of this one
considering the uh you know the fame of
the people involved and this seems like
it would have been right up my alley
yeah I just don't really hear anybody
talking about it and we just totally
came across it at random like it was in
our hey we think he might like this list
of like free movies and I'm just like
hey you were right about that Donald and
Tom carry the movie yeah I mean that's
why you watch this that's why you watch
this movie yeah yeah they do a good job
yeah I thought so too yeah and like I
said there's it's got monsters it's got
famous people it's got side chair
performers it's got tits and ass yeah
cut everything it's got pretty much
everything cool British cars from there
yeah has kind of a decent score too I
guess the score had uh decent like 70s
[__] fashion yeah very groupy yeah
real groovy
um the um
the transfer on the transfer of this
film is is really good the color is good
um you know
so it's well preserved for 70s movie
I liked it yeah I did as well you have a
drink and you watch it and you just like
enjoy it you know and yeah you rip on it
a little bit but that's It's
Entertainment you know it's not you know
you're not watching Shakespeare you know
well the thing about it too is that I
reflexively like make fun of movies just
because that's what I'm like and like I
said because I'm used to watching MST so
much and that doesn't mean that I don't
like the movie it usually means that I'm
like having a good time with the movie
If I was just like sitting there like
dozing off and not saying anything about
the movie that probably means I don't
like it you know unless it's like some
big deep thing that I'm trying to pay
attention to but if it's just like a
movie like this yeah
then yeah I'm gonna make like snarky
comments about it because that's just
how I roll but I said you know but that
doesn't mean I don't like it though
so um so yeah now prior to watching this
like I said we also watched cocaine bear
and then we rewatched Poltergeist yeah
what do we think of cocaine bear
it was okay you know it was just
entertainment I thought it's it started
a little slow
once the bear started attacking and like
tearing off everyone's Limbs and [__]
like that then it started getting like
because some of the get some of the gags
and that were like really really funny
like really over the top because that's
I love that real over the top like
horror comedy type of stuff where it's
just like people like like the one woman
getting her [__] face scraped on the
road and [__] like strangely enough
though I kind of like this one better
well that's what we'll see that's what I
was asking because we actually watched
cocaine bear first and it was like kind
of early and he was like yeah that was
pretty good I was like yeah that was
pretty funny
and then I was like okay well let's
watch Poltergeist because we've been
talking about that so we watched
Poltergeist again and we were talking
about that and then we weren't tired so
we watched another movie and then like
later on I was like well what movie do
you want to review do you want to review
cocaine bear or do you want to review
this one and he's like I think I want to
do the mutations he's like I I found
that one more interesting yeah than
cocaine Bear yeah I thought cocaine bear
was just kind of Sammy just it's a
modern movie it's it's well executed but
yeah it was funny it had like some
really funny gags in it there's a lot of
movies like that that's why I've never
seen anything like this it's weird
you know and it was like I said it was
kind of
it was interesting
I got yeah and I think that's kind of
why I like a lot of these 70s movies
because
I don't know there was just something
about 70s movies that were even though I
was alive for most of the 70s
um and I remember a lot of stuff from
then but there's still like enough time
has passed where you don't really have
the exact same cultural context but then
you kind of do remember it yeah so it's
like so it's this weird Nostalgia but
also like what the [__] is this kind of
thing because there's people were
thinking some weird [__] in the 70s and
everyone was on weird drugs in the 70s
so they came up with some really really
strange ideas where even if you were
alive at the time you're just like where
the [__] did they come up with that like
what are they even talking about a few
years later this would have been morphed
into [__] like reanimator oh movies like
that
even more over the top more zany but
this was
kind of like a weird mixture of like
newfangled 80s stuff
but also 1950s like [__] old school
monster movie it did seem like a 50s
yeah sci-fi movie it's kind of like a
mixture of that like a mad scientist
movie right they just updated it with
color uh hippie clothing groovy clothing
and [__] titties which okay I'm fine
and you're fine with that [__] Tom's
always fighting he's like finally but
the idea of mixing plants and animals
that's [__] 1950s yeah you know
that's so it's kind of like a weird
combo between like a 50s monster movie
and like the 30s and and freaks which
was from the 30s so it's kind of like a
mix between those things but with like a
70s little sprinkling of fondue on top
yeah it's kind of like that it was a
weird mixture of stuff well that's what
I found was really interesting about it
because it was kind of like a hybrid but
it was like an interesting hybrid yeah
it's definitely like an 80s movie no not
at all it was uh it had not made that
breakthrough yet they hadn't made that
leap yet into 80s horror you know
you know Evil Dead and [__]
reanimator and from Beyond and they had
made quite gotten to that [__] 80s B
movie
feel but it was you could see that it
was coming
and this is almost there with like
prophecy
remember about the mutated mutated
barrier yeah and the big ass tadpoles
yeah yeah it was almost kind of like
that big ass raccoons right it's
happening in England though there's a
lot of University shots and [__]
down I guess in the red light districts
where where the dev strip clubs are the
hookers and
and they're in the [__] I think
that's Soho actually yeah and then
they're in the dam
um
the carnival
you know they called it an Italian
Carnival didn't it
oh they might have now I can't even
remember what the maybe that's how they
Justified it because but I mean even by
the 1970s like sideshows were very uh
day class A yeah it wasn't really
something that you saw anymore in the
70s so maybe they were trying to like
fob it off on another country so we
could explain why they were still like a
side show they had some badass 70s
British cars they still look like [__]
from the 60s but there was just
something kind of classy about British
cars even though they weren't very big
they looked big until somebody stood
next to one and you're like damn that
car is little a lot little you have to
like fold yourself yeah
small compared to you know but they were
kind of classy you know flat glass black
the back windows were made pieces of
flat glass kind of [__] split down
the middle and it kind of [__]
tapered to give it a little to give it
like a V shape because they didn't have
any curved glass it's weird you know
weird how they did stuff
I think it was
I don't think it was the rolls
I don't know what kind of car that was
remember the silver car that yeah
Professor kept showing up in and all
that that's right all the chicks getting
the card with him
yeah and he's like 50 and he's got this
looking real hot
chick in her late 20s
hanging off his arm
and then he's got his uh he's got his
friend who's another student and then
his girlfriend
she had half of them get eaten I think
almost all of them do don't they
well see now I would submit and here's
where maybe Donald Pleasence is not in
the sharpest tool in the shed is because
he works at this University right
because they show him like giving a
lecture to the class at the beginning
about genetic engineering
um and this movie I'm gonna say
foreshadowed Jurassic Park he was kind
of talking about that kind of like
genetic engineering that would say so
this is kind of ahead of its time
some of the science center was wonky and
didn't make any sense but it definitely
did like uh foreshadow that
so he works at this University you're
led to presume he has a lab there and he
has a class that he's lecturing to about
his genetic experiments well not his
genetic experience just genetics in
general so he's doing that and then he
gets the bright idea to start kidnapping
students from his class
like to experiment on right because
we're like at least two of those girls
were in his class if not more and that
guy was in his class too I think so it's
like maybe it would be who view to just
go and pick up random people who don't
have any connection to you I mean you
would think it was really suspicious
like if several members of one class
like suddenly disappeared under
mysterious circumstances and he's just
like I have no idea where they went I
don't know yeah sure I'm working on some
genetic stuff where I but I I don't know
what you mean I don't know what you're
implying but yeah so he probably just
should have gone why I don't know why he
didn't go just go pick up buns or like
or prostitutes or something like that
like nobody would wonder if they were
missing
yeah instead of taking like students and
turning them into play animals right
yeah once people that would be missed
right
that's a rookie mistake from your own
class that's what I mean well they had
to have a tight story I know it's like
we can't introduce too many characters
we don't have the budget yeah so it's
like so everybody has to be in this like
but I'm just saying like you know if
you're a genetic scientist who's trying
to turn people into play Animals I mean
probably you should just go pick up
people that don't have any relation to
you that's what I would love this movie
oh big time this is this is kind of what
Ed Wood would have made if he had more
than five dollars yeah this is what
Edward wanted to make yeah
and this is a perfectly respectable yeah
it's cheesy yeah it's from the 70s yeah
it was low budget and stuff like that
but it's a perfectly respectable movie
and like everybody involved like takes
it seriously they're not just like
phoning it in or they're not just like
farting around or anything
especially it makes a good well he
played a villain before he was in one of
the um
yeah or something like that yeah yeah
it's an evil sorcerer was it was it I
was it eye of the tiger that he was in
no uh
Sinbad I think it was I can't remember
which one it was it was one that we
already like the Tiger yeah well either
tiger was the first one that I saw I
think I saw the seventh Voyage of Sinbad
I think that had Tom Baker in it yeah
yeah so he had like so he played he
plays a badass [__] evil vizier he is
good at that yeah it's [__]
I guess he's a Persian sorcerer or
something yeah he does a bunch of cool
[__]
makes it homunculous remember that
that's right he did make a homunculus
yeah and it was was bad to it it was me
to it remember and then I had to go edit
he had to do [__] for him it's like a
spy
that's pretty shitty you can make a
homunculus yeah and then you just like
be addicted he was kind of a dick to it
yeah
yeah he had to keep it under control he
was a dick though well yeah he was a bad
guy he's like well I want to make
something smaller than me just so
specifically so I can be mean to it
because I'm a jerk like that John Baker
could play a good villain yeah so like I
said in this one even though they do try
to like give him some quote unquote
so if I'd go to as far as to say
sympathetic qualities but they give him
qualities that show that he's not like
why he is the way he is
um because of the way he looks and stuff
but he's still he's still a douchebag
though but he's but he plays like a
really good part in it
but you know yeah so if you have Amazon
Prime this is actually on Amazon Prime
and I had never heard of it but it's
actually like yeah it's yeah it's
included with Amazon Prime so you don't
got to pay extra yeah
yeah
um let's talk a little bit about
um Poltergeist too because we because we
watched that one as well even though
we've already kind of reviewed that one
but I hadn't seen it for we could do it
retrospective several years yeah
um so
what so when was the last time we
launched it was probably like three
three four years ago something like that
so many of the story elements yeah you
had forgotten I forgot a lot about it
because you you forgot the whole thing
where it's like when they're moving out
of the hat like before they move out and
you're like oh my God it's over already
I'm like no it's not there's a whole
right he's like what happened with all
the with all the the dead bodies the
dead bodies like popping out of the
ground and stuff is that in part two I
was like no that's in this one yeah I
was like see they they come to a place
where it's like oh you think
everything's solved and it's the end and
everything and then they're like wow and
then they come back and get you yeah it
was it was a good watch
um I think we paid 3.99 to see it again
yeah it's 3.99 everywhere you can't get
it yeah it was worth it I wouldn't mind
actually owning that movie I mean I I
put it right up there with maybe like
Close Encounters of the Third Kind it
has there were a lot of similarities
yeah with this one in Close Encounters
um
there's something about the tone and
I'll tell you what
Steven Spielberg
George Lucas to a certain extent
and uh that new wave of Hollywood
directors in that era of the 70s early
80s
really could capture American Suburbia
the the feel of American
mainstream Suburbia
I think you know about even if you
weren't an American you could probably
understand you could probably
get like a Nostalgia even for an era in
a place that you didn't maybe experience
yourself
but growing up in that era
I remembered it being kind of nostalgic
in that era
yeah I see I know what I'm talking about
I know what you mean yeah it was kind of
affirming to your American lifestyle
you're like yeah that that's the way it
is you know that's the way reality is I
can go back and watch it now and go and
just like uh
feel how much they nailed it that that's
kind of how it felt back then
the cultural expectations were like that
even though not everything adhered to
that but that was just like the median
judged line that was kind of like
normalcy that that was like the normal
line you were trying to be at
but um
those guys guys understood the American
mind real well even Jaws was like that
yeah you could watch jaws and still get
that American feel
yeah I think Steven Spielberg is
probably one of the and I know that
Steven Spielberg technically didn't
direct Poltergeist he wrote it but Toby
Hooper directed it but um
he seemed to be particularly throughout
the 70s and 80s uh the best director at
just like capturing that wistful
Americana Suburbia more than anything
like Americans it's almost kind of like
Mall culture too
there's like that's where you live but
you shopped at a mall yeah and it kind
of had that feeling too
it's weird
that it was a strange era looking back
on it I think what worked with
Poltergeist and the reason why it was
such a big hit was I think they really
did nail that just kind of like
Suburban family Dynamic yeah and they
seemed like a very the way they
interacted with one another seemed very
organic and it seemed like something
that a lot of people could relate to and
like they weren't annoying or anything
like or any more than you know an
average person there wasn't anything
outstanding about them they were just
totally average really right and I think
and and he did a good job at like having
them so that they were so that they had
character they weren't just like Bland
yeah characters but they were still
Universal enough that people could see
themselves it could have been anybody
yeah yeah
anybody could have been in that in that
position or they're like people that you
knew yeah yeah
I also liked and this was maybe kind of
I I don't know if this had been I'm sure
it'd been done previously but one thing
that struck me while we were re-watching
it was that this was one of the first
movies that I saw where like some
haunting [__] started to happen and
instead of people like freaking out and
being scared like you know the mom is
just kind of like cool you know what I
mean it was like experimenting with it
and like trying to figure it out and you
didn't really see that all that much
usually when you saw like horror movies
you know they go in the haunted house or
your house is haunted or whatever and
like you know somebody sees a ghost or
like all the cabinet doors are open or
something like that nobody starts
flipping out like holy [__] it's haunted
ah and I was like you know what I mean
but I like that they didn't he didn't go
that route because I kind of feel like
it's more realistic because like if
something happened like that where you
turn around and like all your [__]
chairs are stacked on the table like
it'd be scary but you'd also be like wow
like you've like tried to figure it out
you know what I mean so I like that they
I liked that he kind of did that man
right that's what I'm saying so that's
kind of I feel like that's kind of more
that closer to like how most people
would act some people something would
scare you you might run from it but then
you'd run right back
see it again to see if it was still
there that kind of stuff
trying to figure out what had happened
and I love when like when when the dad
gets home and the mom's all excited and
she's like trying to tell him about
all the stuff she's been doing that day
and she tries to get Carol Ann to like
sit in her place and slide and the kids
like hmm I guess she's she's doing this
all day and she's like over it yeah
yeah funny so it's like all this amazing
like Paranormal stuff is just like old
hat now because she's been like putting
up with it all day long so I just think
that's really funny
flick I think it holds up the special
effects of course you can see that a lot
of stuff is kind of drawn it's like it's
animated by hand yeah and some of the
smoke and the Rays you know what I mean
but it's okay you know what I mean
you're kind of forgiving of such an old
classic movie you know that's an old
movie now yeah 82 and
the uh
the Practical effects still kind of hold
up the dead bodies
uh the one part where the guy pulls his
face off in the mirror who hallucinates
it it doesn't quite look as good as I
remembered it the hands are kind of like
at the wrong angle and the yeah I
noticed that because it looked like the
hands were kind of backwards yeah and
the face doesn't really come apart that
well you know it wouldn't fly today
but you know it's okay it was a good
movie I told you like I saw this movie I
was 10 was the first time I saw it and
that that scene of that dude pulling his
face up like scared the [__] [__] out
of me yeah what was interesting was uh
the Interiors of that house
how new that house looked and I
remembered when houses like that look
new
now houses like that all look old and
run down well yeah because nobody makes
them one of them nobody makes them like
that anymore another thing that was uh
kind of a throwback to another era
the daughter was 16 in high school in
the [__] cut the construction worker
guys were [__] cat caller yeah Mama
and that was like something that would
happen in 82 it wouldn't happen today
they wouldn't even put that in a movie
today
yeah I don't know about that but yeah
they wouldn't put that in the movie I
don't think probably not no
dude still do that though on a 16 year
old girl yeah of course they do really
yeah I haven't seen it yeah I've seen it
yeah all right
I haven't seen it they still absolutely
do that I saw [__] like that in the 60s
in the 70s in the 80s I mean yeah I mean
I've I had never stopped seeing that
like it's just no I'm just saying that
it's like it happens all the time where
it happens all the time you haven't seen
that yes I have okay where where'd you
see that where's the last time you saw
that I don't know where the last time
was no I'm not making it up have you
seen anybody call this cat calling a 16
year old girl
okay last time I saw it was when I
worked at that print shop and I used to
which was
2014 2015 something like that
and I used to take walks and sometimes
you'd see like teenagers walking up from
school and yeah people used to dudes
used to cat calling from Cars and Stuff
how old were they were they in high
school too
didn't look like it
good didn't look like it
it does happen Tom just because it
doesn't happen to you doesn't mean it
doesn't happen
[Laughter]
but uh but yeah so I don't know like
it's the weird thing about Poltergeist
is that I've seen it so many times that
it's gonna sound weird but it's like I
almost expected it to be like longer I
almost expected that there like I always
thought there was like more to it
you know but like when I'm watching it
I'm just kind of like oh we're at this
part already like it seemed to go really
fast well it's basic
yeah it's a basic movie
yeah yeah I mean uh
it's from it's 1982.
and it's just kind of like a blueprint
for for that kind of movie yeah but it's
just
I think it kind of captured the time
though
yeah it did but it's pretty accurate so
do Close Encounters
yes encounters kind of captured the late
70s
kind of how it felt very early 80s what
year was that maybe 79
what closing counters yeah
yeah something like that maybe 79. uh I
think I can't remember it might have
been 1980. I can't remember Jimmy gar
yeah never heard nothing she was young
we reviewed that too a couple years ago
I think we kind of went on a hole kick
yeah
I know it's I like Poltergeist Better
Than Close Encounters but that's just
because like I said I'm not super super
into like
Cypher like a more alien type movies I
like playing a more Ghost type of movies
but the thing about Poltergeist too is
that sometimes even though I've seen it
a bunch of times like every time I see
it I always forget how [__] over the
top it is like man some crazy [__]
happens in that house
I kind of feel like if you if you did
that nowadays like I kind of feel like
people would be like yeah let's tone it
down a little bit because
all kind of [__] happens in there like
just crazy like Monsters appear in front
of the door and all that kind of stuff
and I feel like if you did that now
people would be like yeah it's a little
much but I don't know for some reason it
works
like in that movie it works I think if
you did it now it would be too much what
like just how like um just the
over-the-topness of the manifestations
because it really does kind of like ramp
up you know what I mean like it starts
out pretty subtle with like just a
little [__] with the TV and everything
like that but then it like ramps up to
like the dudes ripping
and the tree tries to eat the kid and it
was like [__] there's like all those
ghosts like walking down yeah and like
stuff like that so I kind of feel like
if you did that now well I maybe not it
maybe it depends on
how it's
um like how you handle it because I've
certainly seen some more recent horror
movies that did kind of go over the top
of the Paranormal manifestations and
they got away with it but you have to
really but then I've seen some that went
over the top with it where it was just
like way too much and I just thought
they should have dialed it back because
I tend to think horror works better when
it's subtle but for some reason
I always really liked Poltergeist and I
think even though it's like way over the
top but I don't know I kind of like it
and the second one is actually really
good too with that creepy preacher guy
yeah even though they kind of a little
bit well I don't know if they
they sort of retrofitted
the the story
I don't remember I didn't remember that
being over the top for 82 though yeah I
mean for 82 and that was like I don't
think I didn't see that one in the movie
theaters I saw that one on on cable it
must have been a year or two after it
came out in theater
and we just
I just saw it as like impressive yeah
you know what I mean like yeah big ass
head yeah a big ass head yeah okay wow I
fell through the [__] door you know
and he came out through the ceiling
it was just
look at it today it's pretty cheesy
in a way you know yeah but it didn't
matter it was just it was something of
its time
yeah the with all the red goop on the
tennis balls yeah
then they came out had red goop on them
and they put them in the [__]
put them in the uh in the tub yeah yeah
with the jello yeah
yeah like I actually we were watching it
and uh and I asked them I was like so if
I got sucked into another like um the
death Dimension would you come in there
on a rope and get me pull me out through
the ceiling
yes if they were to do that today they'd
have a whole CGI sequences of what was
in the spirit world and everything
yeah
I'm kind of glad they didn't do that
though they're right because you could
just like imagine it
well the thing about it is it because if
they showed it then it would just be
like a disappointment because people
would be like well that wasn't what I
was expecting to be I don't know there
was just something by the time you know
the Ghostbusters was pretty [__] over
the top too well well that was a comedy
so they could get away with him but I
think just that imagery was acceptable
for that time
yeah you could get away with a lot more
stuff in the 80s yeah than maybe
nowadays because like I said I think and
maybe the reason that you can't get away
with it nowadays is because they already
did it in the 80s and it worked in the
80s but it's like now if you try to do
it people would be like man yeah
yeah it's just it's not the same like
the cultural context is not the same
but yeah so it's like it worked because
you had never seen it before right now
everybody's seen it yeah and it's just
kind of like and now if you did it now
people would be like oh you're just
ripping off whatever well they would
just think it was cheesy all right yeah
we're thinking it was cheesy and you
were ripping off something else but yeah
so Poltergeist 2 was good Poltergeist
three was awful unfortunately because
that was like the last movie that has
ever worked it before she died and it's
sad because she looked
she didn't look that good in that movie
either like she looked kind of bloated
because I was like not moving and then
she died before they even finished it
because like she has a body double in
some of them and I didn't really like
that they moved it to like a I know that
they were trying to like change the
scenery up and everything like that but
they moved it to that
um
like high-rise apartment building with
all the mirrors which was which would
have been a good idea but I don't know I
just don't think it was executed very
good I do like the second one though
even though like I said they did kind of
like
redo the backstory a little bit to
shoehorn and all the
the thing with the cult and that creepy
preacher and everything but the preacher
was so creepy that I'll allow it you
know
um yeah so were you ready to wrap it up
yep all right
so the next show is on Wednesday night
and this should be a fun one because we
are doing at long last we're doing
another
mysteries of rock and roll uh this is
gonna be volume two we did volume one
but way the [__] back on episode 69 and
I looked it up the other day and I was
like because I didn't want to repeat
anything and I think on that one we did
um the Elvis Orion thing
we did like um Dark Side of the Moon and
The Wizard of Oz we did like some other
stuff so on this one probably we're
gonna do mostly like mysterious deaths
and disappearances or
or ones where um there's some
controversy about like whether they
committed suicide or were murdered or
whatever so we're gonna talk about that
so that should be fun because I've been
wanting to do that show for a long time
and it finally won in the bowl so yay
um but yeah so hopefully you guys can
come by on Wednesday night for that
um so yeah I guess that will do it for
this show which kind of was sensibly
about the mutations but we ended up
doing kind of a triple feature anyway
so hopefully you guys will come by on
Wednesday night when we stream again and
have a good rest of your night have a
good day tomorrow we'll see you
Wednesday good night